- [Interviewer] All right.
Mariah.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Now where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Mariah] San Pedro, California.
- [Interviewer] South of LA?
- [Mariah] Yes.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family,
you had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- No, I had my, my mom.
My biological dad he left my mom
when she was pregnant with me,
so I don't, I don't know who he is.
My stepdad came into
my life when I was two
but even then my grandmother,
my mom's mom still raised
me as her her child.
- [Interviewer] So your grandmother...
- My grandmother took
care of her kids, kids.
Cause that's what GM's do.
- [Interviewer] And how would
you describe your childhood?
- Difficult.
Dysfunctional, abusive.
- [Interviewer] What kind of abuse?
- Physical, verbal, emotional.
- [Interviewer] Everything but sexual?
Were you transgender or gay
or something like that
early on in your life?
- I was, but I didn't know what it was
or how to identify as it as it.
- [Interviewer] Did it,
did it cause problems?
Did people pick on you
or anything like that?
- I was different.
So kids in school of
course they make fun of it.
Talk about, physicists and gays and,
but it really didn't bother me then.
And it wasn't until I found out who I was
at the age of 11, that I
wanted to be a trans woman.
And then that put separation between me
and some of my family
members, my mom, especially.
- [Interviewer] So you didn't
feel very accepted as a kid.
- Not at all.
- [Interviewer] And how
were your high school years?
- You know, as we got older
all the kids I went to school
with in elementary school
from kindergarten on up
were basically the same
kids I went to school with.
Middle school and high school
and they got used to me.
They knew who I was so
they didn't have the
judgmental walls.
They got, they got to know me.
Mhhm.
- [Interviewer] So you had
some real friends as a kid.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
And where'd your life go
after you left the school?
- Well, I possibly go into the military,
that didn't pay out well
because I didn't show up
for bootcamp because it
was being a military brat.
It's always been my family's legacies
and things to join some
branch in the military.
- [Interviewer] So you felt,
you felt pressure to do that?
- I did.
And when my grandmother
and my mom finally agreed
on something, that was one thing.
And so to show them that I could do it
I went and scored one
of the highest scores
on ASVAB test possible.
I got sworn in scheduled
to leave September 5th
of 2000 and go to bootcamp
after I graduated high school.
I just didn't.
I chose a different path.
I chose one for me, not for
what my family wanted me to be.
- [Interviewer] And
where'd you go from there?
- Well, nuts.
Same year my grandmother passed away
and that was like my rock.
That was the person that
I turned to confine it in
for everything.
After she left I didn't have
nobody to trust it, to turn to.
So I moved out to Hollywood
and my roommate there he's
like he was a gang member
but for a side hustle, he went
in, sold his male penis parts
to older dudes and he was
getting high on crystal meth.
And it wasn't until my
grandmother, passed away December
First of 2000, I found out December 15th
the first line of crystal ice snow,
it was on December 16th of 2000.
- [Interviewer] Are you
still using it today?
- No.
- [Interviewer] What are you using today?
- Cigarette.
- [Interviewer] That's it?
- Contact weave.
- [Interviewer] No drugs?
- No.
- [Interviewer] What are
you doing for money now?
- There's a couple of things.
One is my they've been home
caretaker for my cousin
and I have a side fun hustle.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Understood. Understood.
And your little side hustle
that you do, is that,
is that problematic at times?
- Hmm.
It can be, but it's not
like I'm, I, some people
have to be out there doing
whatever it takes to survive.
I just like sometimes to
go for strolls at night.
- [Interviewer] What's that?
- I like going for walks at night.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And I'm sure when you
go for a walk at night,
you get lots of attention.
- I do.
And, I am grown.
- [Interviewer] You are grown.
You're free to do whatever you want.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] You've been arrested then?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Never.
- Never.
- [Interviewer] Because technically
that kind of work is illegal.
- Yes. Because you're
not paying taxes on it.
- [Interviewer] (chuckles)That's
one of the reasons yes.
What's it cre, what's the
craziest thing one of your
boyfriends has asked you to
do when they pick you up?
- (chuckles) There's been quite a few.
I've had some with feet fetishes.
I've had some with wanted to be dominated
and they even wanted to be urinated on.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] There are
these guys that are...
- Like this are like
well-established men who live
like in the Hollywood
Hills and stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] Are they
married sometimes you think?
- Yes.
Most of the guys that I have come across,
they've always, they've been married.
- [Interviewer] They are on the down low?
- Yeah. You could say that
or it's just them thing that
they haven't been able to talk
with their partner about that,
that they have tendencies
of wanting to experiment
with this and do with this.
And their partner is
not able to understand
that it's not taking away from
how they really feel about them.
So it's just this other part
that's not being satisfied.
- [Interviewer] It's an
interesting world out there.
Isn't it?
- It is. Its a funny world.
- [Interviewer] What emotions
do you deal with most?
Are you depressed at times?
Do you get to angry?
Anxious?
- [Mariah] Angry, no.
I try to, I, it's hard to make me angry
but I do have depression,
failure and failing.
Struggling to make everybody else happy
and to try to do what I feel is
what they believe is what's right.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel misunderstood,
especially by your family?
- Not any more.
I did at one time,
but my mom has come to acceptance.
We have a mutual agreement where as long
as it's just the immediate
family, which would be consists
of my, my, my stepdad, my
mom, my sister, her husband
they could call me whatever
they want to call me
in around them.
But if we're out in the public,
you call me anything outside
of your daughter or my name
that I choose to be called,
I'm not answering you.
So don't take it personal.
It's just, I don't have to.
And so they accept that one.
- [Interviewer] What's the most important
lesson you've learned?
- To put pride and ego aside
and know when to ask
for help when I need it.
Instead of trying to not
want to put my burden
on others and act like I got it.
- [Interviewer] What's most
misunderstood about your,
your lifestyle?
- Gender it's a choice.
And I understand both sides of that.
Yes. It's a choice to choose
to whatever clothes you're
going to put on that day.
But it's not your choice
of who you identify,
who you identify with as a person.
That's a battle that
we struggle with daily
trying to get seen as
who we truly feel we are.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
Have you been in love before?
- Yes.
A couple of times.
- [Interviewer] Would you
describe yourself as happy?
- Am I happy now?
- [Interviewer] Generally.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What's
the hardest part of,
of living this lifestyle?
- Ignorances, people's
ignorances and unwilling,
they want to be accepted
for who and what they are
and whatever lifestyle
choices they choose to make
but they can't offer that same in return,
to the next person.
- [Interviewer] What advice would you give
to a young person going
through what you went through?
- [Mariah] Stay strong,
stay believe in yourself
because it doesn't matter
what anybody else thinks
or believes it's how you
really believe in yourself.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
And Mariah thank you so
much for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] I wish you
the best of luck out there.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.